hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the championship
showdown chess960 edition or the chest
9x edition as they're calling it
Fabiano Carano vs. garry kasparov this
is game for off yesterday's match so
first they played two games of the rapid
chest and now two games of the blade so
like we've mentioned in the previous
video first game ended in a draw second
game Kasparov blundered their winning
position so far beyond a Fabiana won the
game third game was a blitz game Khurana
won that game and this is the fourth
game the last day over the first day so
let's see what happened there because
Quran opens with nice to be three at the
same way he did in the previous game
we've shown where he had the white
pieces with d5 Kasparov continues in the
same fashion sorry about that
and now f4 by Caruana not efore efore
was played in the previous game where
Kasparov just continued with d4 but here
fabric goes for f4 now getting the d4
square for himself so Casper will not be
able to overextend with the pawn we have
Knight to be six but by Kasparov and now
II for Queen a four by Kasparov you know
in classical chess see you will often
hear a thing don't bring your queen out
too early but no one said that about
chess960 at least no one said it so far
so Queensway for already bringing the
Queen into the attack and night to g3
another principle move by Fabi also in
classical chess you will often hear
bring your Knights into the game before
your bishops so here Fabi goes with the
same principled ideas we have e 6 and
then out d4 I'm grabbing more space in
the center and Knight to c4 now by
Kasparov playing again breaking the
principles with the with the same piece
twice in the opening but we don't know
if the same principles apply in chess960
or chess 9 elects so push up the d3 by
Corona and now bush up the b4 just
bringing more pieces into the attack
Kaspar once the wants to start the
attack against the white king
he's hoping for c3 to get a weakening of
the Kings position and then just move
the bishop but Corona says no you're not
getting any weakening in the position so
Queen f1 now preparing to capture
here on c4 although it's hard to say if
it's yeah there is there is the threat
for example let's say if a six is played
now you can capture and now you cannot
claim the Queen with for example Bishop
d2 trick because well you're just gonna
play Knight captures and then the Queen
is protected so there are no tricks such
as this so we have to do something about
the Bishop captures on c4 and Kasparov
plays b5 he doesn't like tonight a five
so the Knights get traded off and the
game just continuously plays b5 so a
slight weakening of the position in
front of the King but he captures on c4
ever happens he will get a nice open B
file for his rook he captures on d5 by
Caruana he captures on d5 and now Knight
to c5 and the knight has to be captured
if you don't capture the night you lose
the game for example if Queen a5 these
two squares are covered by the night
just Bishop f5 check wins the game and
the King has no squares you have to
block then you first lose the rook then
Queen e2 just goes after mate and you
will suffer more material losses and
very soon lose the game so after Knight
c5 with bushel characters the knight has
to be captured d captures on c5 and the
nagas part of captures on a2 we have
Queen captures on a tube and the Bishop
to b4 the bishop will now help out with
the defense of the King and also you are
threatening to capture on g7 so f6
another game Kasparov just plays of six
so it's obviously fine in mountain
Knight the f5 going after the g7 pawn
with Knight to g6 and now just Knight
captures on g7 King Tubby seven Kasparov
will now try to hide the King so he can
use the palace for his rooks and now
Knight back to h5 going after the f6
pawn you cannot capture on f6 right away
because the the bishop kinda has to keep
an eye on the e3 square so tonight's the
h5 and now Knight back the e7 planning
Knight to c6 and here bush of characters
on f6 so it's a very delicate position
white obviously has a
had the advantage of what here Kasparov
just goes on an all-out attack he could
go rook e8 prepare to move the knight
just get the roof door saver square but
he does it without waiting he plays
Knight to c6 and here he's offering the
rookin da to start some sort of an
attack but it's a police game so you
can't really offer spend a lot of time
on on analyzing the position but Fabi
first eliminates one of the closer
attackers so first Bishop captures on c4
he can always capture on d8 with B
captures on c4 now Kasparov will get
maybe the open semi open B file for his
rook Bishop captures on d8 and now rook
captures on the eighth ninth chapter
seems like a more logical idea as you
want to keep the rook here for for
attacking purposes but after Knight f6
for example you O king day 8 the free up
the rook and give up the piece c3 seems
like a nice idea but it doesn't really
do anything for example Queen to f3 c
capture some b2 with check you're gonna
escape king d2 and now you have to do
something about this pawn here for
example c6 and after something like
Knights the e7 the White King is very
safe you're just gonna hide kingi
talking if sorry I can get to King f2
maybe even King g3 and the White King
will be very safe there and you're just
down in material so white would be
completely winning here so Kasparov
decided on rook captures on d8 and now
you have Knight to f6 we have night to
be four by Kasparov and now Queen f3 the
Queen will now help out with the defense
of the Queen side here and also it's on
a very nice diagonal iron Kasparov King
you can start pushing your deep on right
away
so here Kasparov played Queen to a4 he's
threatening mate I thought maybe Queen
to a if I was also interesting as it
threatens this very nice modern Knights
the eight you met mate but it wouldn't
be a problem because here now Fabi can
actually castle and this is one thing I
wanted to mention because I got it
completely wrong in the previous video
as I don't play chess 960 myself the way
you castle
in chess960 it doesn't matter what's the
position but once you castle King said
or who inside the final position of king
and rook has to be the same as it would
be in classical chest so for example if
we Castle kingside here we just bring
the King over here the King goes all the
way to g1 and the rook has to be an f1
so this is what happens if you Castle in
this position and Bobby said in an
interview after the game that he
completely forgot that he could still
Castle I mean who wouldn't forget in in
such crazy position but yeah after the
screen to have to remove and cuz perhaps
Queen to a4 you could Castle but even
after Queen a5 and threatening this
modern maid even if you forgot you could
Castle c3 is perfectly fine for black
for example might be three check King to
c2 and you don't have a good follow up
here so that's that
now the the the white thing will be very
safe after Queen to f3 Kasparov played
Queen today for attacking the c2 pond
going for mate right away and now b3 by
karana he also doesn't mind opening up
the B file as now his rook occupies the
same file as Kasparov skin and now you
have to decide if you go neither to
check it seems like a very nice idea but
it still doesn't do much King D - you
play c3 with check King a one and the
King nicely escapes you don't have you
don't have a good follow up here
so after be three we have Queens the a2
by Kasparov threatening this mate
but now again a corona forgets that he
can just castle to safety here so
instead a corona goes Queen to c3
guarding the mating square with a wood
to the Queen cuz portal goes Queen to a3
with check and now you have to be
careful you can't play a little bit or
something because Knight a to check will
pick up the Queen so we have Kings to d2
by karana and now d4 and now it's a
completely crazy position Kasparov is in
an all-out attacking mode but there is
one move that that can save Caruana so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this winning the idea for Corona in
this position while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations for
finding such a nice winning idea that is
also a check and for those of you that
just want to enjoy the show Queen to f3
check and now everything just falls in
the right place after Queen to have to
recheck casparo resign the game as there
is really nothing more to do here for
example if you move the King King b8 you
just get beat captures on c4 and now
everything opens up
Kasparov Queen is under attack if you
trade then
Fabi will first grab the night with
check only then recapture the Queen but
there isn't all that much to do you
could try Queen a4 again threatened to
capture on c2 but then just c3 also
possible Queen to c2 check you can even
allow this king that you want and there
is no fall yeah there's nothing to do
you can't capture here on anything as
the rook is hanging and well next move
you're just gonna lose this light so
there's nothing to do even after a 5
just see capture so it's not a problem
so that's one of the possibilities and
another after Queen f3 check King b8
again B captures and c4 like we said
opens up everything you could try 3 with
black still not a problem
c3 again wins the night you can't move
the night to do to the pin pawn captures
is a threat
Queen a to check you can allow this King
you want even D to check King f2 and
there are no more follow-ups once you
play a 5 or something seek after Sun
before is coming and you are just well
you're just down material here and you
are very quickly getting destroyed once
this position opens up you're either
getting mated or you're gonna suffer
severe material loss yeah
after this Queen to f3 check esparto
resigned and corona won the first day
with a result of three and a half to
half so only first game was drawn and
then corona won three games in a row
which is not all that all that was well
strange as the same fate happens to
occur Nakamura who lost three and a half
to half 11 Aragon but 11 is just the so
so so great in every type of chess he
plays Bach house he plays chess 960 he
enjoys all types of chess you know some
some say that this
sometimes maybe worsens his classical
chess skills but he he says he that it
actually improves it for example when he
plays back house that playing a lot of
Bach house helps him in classical chest
so he can sort of imagine where he wants
some of the pieces to be in class for
chess and then just bring them there
which is something you have to do in
Bach house so it's always interesting to
hear him say anything about chess and
any types of chess in this case chase no
chess960 sure up today is the second day
they will play four more games and if
you have any game that you've enjoyed
feel free to suggest it and we're gonna
cover it as I'm really starting to enjoy
chess960 because even even if it's not
classical chest you can imagine the
starting position as already a
completely new game and see how the
players you know just brawl it out
without any opening theory which is
quite refreshing because I think in the
last 100 videos we had like maybe 4:45
Queen Queen game Queens gambit declined
and 4545 rule opus openings and that's
just that's just I mean it's great but
it's also refreshing to sometimes have a
completely new position already starting
for a move one so that's the game once
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Jeff graves William Carney
Danno Hanlon Parker Grand Prix and
Michael lp's for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing this short coverage of the
chess960 championship showdown
continuing the Capablanca saga and
checking up on your suggestions thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day